it's fun to see how fine-tuned some
things are so like even in your Kimmel
set how fine-tuned were mannerisms and
pauses like how dialed in was that set
well that sets pretty dialed in well
Mike I know what I want to do but yeah
when I'm when I'm just doing a longer
set I mean I'm waving just at everything
like it's a good way like if someone
tells you I can give them a little wave
like that like you know or a beep people
have weird laughs sometimes so instead
of having to address it I just give them
a wave and the audience gets it they're
like we heard that too
yeah I don't know why it just I think
that's something that when the first
time I saw you perform like that
subtlety mm-hmm just hit I don't know
why but sometimes it's like if they're
beat someone's heckling you sometimes it
can be like a Jedi mind trick you know
you're like all right just quells yeah a
lot of times not always but a lot of
times you get people that are too drunk
to get anything you know they don't they
don't get if you and some people just
want to be made fun of mm-hmm like after
the show you didn't make fun of them
they're disappointed I had a guy go I
was like hey I like that shirt and he's
like yeah wore this so you'd make fun of
me I was like oh if I'd have seen you I
would have I would have did it and I was
just humoring him and then he goes what
would you have said I was like all right
well I'm not just gonna roast you right
here on demand right yeah but not it
yeah and that's why you know like people
one guy was dressed like the day man or
maybe after the always sunny my Charley
day did then I don't know what day man
or night man he's like the body suit
yeah we had though like a full green
suit or something right up front and
it's like I feel like that guy he wore
that to be made fun of yeah everybody
noticed you dressed the obvious right
how do you normally deal with hecklers
what have you found to be the most
efficient way well I think for me just
being nice is the best way because if I
don't if I if I get like any kind of
like aggressive like I feel like the
audience gets weird because I've just
been nice and fun the whole time and all
of a sudden I'm like shut up people are
like Oh what happened but it's it's
hecklers
really bother me so much it's just like
I had a guy in the front row at a show
and he was really drunk and he was just
he was just almost just making comments
to me that no one else could hear yo I'm
in there there's no I was like can you
guys kick this guy out of here and and
they didn't he was very muscular but I
tried to make fun of it a little bit and
then just be like and and and we work
through it we worked through it yeah but
some of those it's like there's nothing
you can do it's like I just like that
guy to be quiet and just leave but it's
like is it kind of guy that like even in
a setup he's commenting on your setups
and it's and he think I mean he he came
up to me after the show he was trying to
hug me he was like I was like dude like
I don't know just he was like but that
helped that helped a little I was like I
just want you to know I told him I said
I just want you to know you didn't help
this show I don't want you to leave here
thinking that you helped thinking that
you were part of the show you weren't I
didn't enjoy it and he didn't get it and
as he was leaving he was asking the
feature he was like I helped right yeah
it's like did that's the thing with a
lot of hecklers is they almost feel like
they are helping ya always most really
aren't even ill-intentioned they really
just think they're helping ya so it is I
guess being the nice that nice piece is
crucial to not lose the audience yeah
they all think he's well not they'd all
think he's helping but yeah they're like
what's wrong with this guy up there
why'd he get so mad yeah
but it's like you know when you're in a
zone and the audience is listening you
can really just tell your jokes and it's
a great time for everyone but one person
can ruin that whole mood yeah so that's
why being nice and just being like hey I
appreciate you being here well you will
you go back and forth with them or
you're like thanks for being here and
you kind of keep moving and that they
keep going then you come back to yeah I
try to just move on yeah move on but you
know sometimes like just repeating what
someone says can be funny like if they
say some weird thing you just repeat it
into the microphone then the audience
laughs and then and then it could be fun
but then you're it's almost like in
their minds they're like oh I gave him
that joke yeah I'm gonna give him
another way
you know I'm gonna keep this going
mm-hmm so yeah I mean I my goal is to
just be the kind of comic that no one
wants to heckle you're just too nice of
a guy they don't want yes thurb you yeah
and I'm not I'm not touching on any
subject that could really be sensitive
to them but you you know I did a show
and Sue st. Marie Michigan and I think
they have like a you know Native
American population so I have a joke
about baskets just a general basket joke
and then this lady goes baskets are
sacred to us oh I was like all right all
right if I can't make fun of baskets is
this too far it was a help for him oh
yeah yeah that's like religion joke all
right all right move on from that yeah I
was like wow I had no idea make it in
front of a sweetgrass basket was was so
intense have you ever been booed onstage
[Music]